veamos la ecuación pib para una economía
abierta pib es igual al ingreso nacional
y este es igual al consumo más la
inversión más el gasto del gobierno y
como es una economía abierta sumamos las
exportaciones netas lo primero que vamos
a hacer será despejar las exportaciones
netas vamos a restar esto de ambos lados
de la ecuación nos queda que el ingreso
nacional menos el consumo menos el gasto
del gobierno menos la inversión
todo esto es igual a las exportaciones
netas y aquí es igual el ingreso
nacional menos el consumo menos el gasto
del gobierno esto de aquí es igual al
ahorro nacional es ese mayúscula así que
podemos decir que el ahorro nacional
menos la inversión es igual a las
exportaciones netas
vamos a usar esto para pensar en los
flujos de capital primero vamos a
asegurarnos de comprender lo que es el
flujo de capital primero veamos qué es
la entrada de capital que significa
significa que extranjeros están
invirtiendo capital en nuestro país para
comprar activos en nuestro
por otra parte la salida de capital
significa que residentes de nuestro país
están sacando capital del país para
comprar activos extranjeros entonces
ustedes creen que los ahorros - las
inversiones sean una entrada de capital
o una salida de capital podemos ver esto
como que ahorramos una gran cantidad y
una pequeña parte de esa cantidad la
invertimos y qué hacemos con lo que
sobra pues tiene que salir del país
porque si lo invertimos dentro del país
sería parte de esta y mayúscula por lo
que esta es una salida neta de capital
que a veces vemos abreviada como ese en
ese de aquí viene la idea de que la
exportación neta es igual a la salida de
capital vamos a escribirlo para
enfatizar la salida neta de capital es
igual a la exportación neta porque tiene
sentido esto imaginemos que la
exportación neta es positiva esto
significa que hay más extranjeros
comprando nuestros activos o bienes de
lo que nosotros estamos comprando bienes
o activos extranjeros como van a pagar
los extranjeros por dichos bienes
en detalles del cambio de divisas
podemos pensar en que una forma de pagar
es que los extranjeros venden sus
activos o bienes extranjeros a personas
en nuestro país por lo que tenemos
personas en nuestro país que compran
bienes extranjeros para que los
extranjeros puedan a su vez comprar
nuestros bienes
ese es desde nuestro punto de vista una
salida neta de capital
espero que esto tenga sentido para
ustedes otra forma de ver esto es
reacomodar estas variables donde
restamos la exportación neta de ambos
lados de la ecuación y sumamos la
inversión en ambos lados nos queda el
ahorro nacional - la exportación neta
igual a la inversión y si las
exportaciones netas son igual a la
salida neta de capital a que será igual
el negativo de la exportación neta pues
será la entrada neta de capital con esto
podemos escribir otra ecuación y noten
que aunque estamos aplicando álgebra
esto nos ayuda a comprender mejor estos
conceptos podemos decir que los ahorros
más la entrada neta de capital
es igual a la inversión esto tiene
sentido porque si tenemos una inversión
en nuestro país porque estamos
construyendo carreteras o fábricas de
dónde viene el capital para dicha
inversión puede venir del ahorro
nacional o puede venir del capital
extranjero que entra a nuestro país y se
usa para inversión en resumen
manipulamos la ecuación del pib para una
economía abierta para llegar a esta idea
de que las salidas netas de capital son
igual a las exportaciones netas o que el
negativo de las exportaciones netas que
es la importación neta es igual a la
entrada neta de capital nos vemos en el
siguiente vídeo